PROTECT OUR FREEDOM.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF THE
TONIGHT’S "ANGLE."
BEFORE THE PRESIDENT’S DRASTIC
MEASURES TONIGHT THAT HE
INTRODUCED.
EARLIER TESTIMONY BY DR. FAUCI
FROM THE CDC WAS SOBERING AND
SCARY TO HEAR.
>> WE WILL SEE MORE CASES AND
THINGS WILL GET WORSE THAN THEY
ARE RIGHT NOW.
HOW MUCH WORSE WE WILL GET WILL
SPEND ON OUR ABILITY TO DO 2
THINGS.
.
TO CONTAIN THE INFLUX OF PEOPLE
INVECTED
INVECTED -- INFECTED COMING FROM
THE OUTSIDE AND THE ABILITY TO
CONTAIN WITHIN OUR OWN COUNTRY.
IF WE DON’T DO SERIOUS
MITIGATION WE WILL BE WEEKS
BEHIND.
WE HAVE TO CHANGE OUR BEHAVIOR
AND ASSUME WE WILL GET HIT.
>> Laura: AMERICANS HEAR THAT
AND WANT TO KNOW WHAT NEXT?
AMERICA HAS GONE FROM RIDING
HIGH TO REELING IN JUST A FEW
SHORT WEEKS.
MAYBE A WEEK ACTUALLY.
THIS DANGEROUS HEALTH CRISIS
COULD DOVE TAIL INTO A POLITICAL
CRISIS.
SOME HOPE FOR A POLITICAL
>> WE CAN’T TRUST THIS
PRESIDENT.
NOT ONLY IS HE A LIAR.
HE DOESN’T BELIEVE IN ANYTHING
SCIENTIFIC.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES CAN’T BE RELIED UPON ON.
HE NEEDS TO SHUT HIS MOUTH.
>> Laura: THAT’S NICE.
IT’S EASY FOR ELECTED OFFICIALS
TO SHOUT OR WHATEVER THAT WAS
FROM HER FROM THEIR POLITICAL
CORNERS.
IT’S HARDER BUT WISER TO PROCEED
CAREFUL.
THIS MOMENT REMINDS ME A LITTLE
BIT OF THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH
OF 9-11.
I REMEMBER.
I WAS HERE.
MANY OF US WERE FREAKING OUT AND
FRIGHTENED AND EXPECTING FOR
TERRORISM.
CONGRESS RUSHED TO PASS THE
PATRIOT ACT AND WE LEARNED THERE
WERE ABUSES THERE AND IN BOTH
WARS THOUSANDS WERE KILLED.
AND FAMILIES WERE SHATTER BY
LOSSES.
A DOMINO EFFECT OF INSTABILITY
IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
WHEN KEY DECISIONS WERE MADE IN
THE 2000S.
FEW THOUGHT ABOUT THE LONG-TERM
RAMIFICATIONS AND THOUGHT OF THE
POTENTIAL OF LASTING DAMAGE TO
THE UNITED STATES.
BACK TO TODAY, AS DR. FAUCI SAID
WE HAVEN’T SEEN THE WORST OF IT.
WE MUST TAKE AGGRESSIVE MEASURES
SO OUR HOSPITALS ARE NOT
OVERWHELMED.
AT SOME POINT AND WE HOPE SOON,
AS WITH SARS AND H1N1 TOO THIS
WILL PASS.
IT’S A SEVERE PROBLEM BUT LIKELY
SHORT TERM.
AS WE CONSIDER MEASURES TO FIGHT
THE VIRUS’S SPREAD WE NEED TO
THINK LONGER TERM.
THIS INCLUDE PROTECTING OUR
ECONOMY.
THIS MAY SHOCK YOU, BUT I AM
GOING TO COMPLIMENT NANCY
PELOSI.
>> SHOULD THE CAPITOL BE CLOSED
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME?
>> NO.
>> Laura: GOOD FOR HER.
WHILE WE SHOULD BE MINDFUL OF
MITIGATING COMMUNITY SPREAD, WE
SHOULD TRY TO STRIKE A BALANCE
HERE.
WHERE THE RISK IS MINIMAL THE
BUSINESS OF AMERICA MUST GO ON.
FDR TOLD US THE ONLY THING TO
FEAR IS FEAR ITSELF.
FEAR ALONE IS NOT A SOUND BASIS
FOR MAKING SIGNIFICANT DECISIONS
THAT IMPINGE ON OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS LIKE
FREEDOM TO ASSEMBLE AND FREE
SPEECH.
SHOULDN’T WE THINK ABOUT THE
TYPE OF PRECEDENT WE ARE SETTING
HERE?
SHOULD WE ASSUME GOING FORWARD
ANY TIME A SERIOUS DISEASE
MIGRATES HERE FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY, WE HAVE TO CLOSE
EVERYTHING DOWN?
AT ONE ECONOMIST SAID THAT COULD
BE MORE CATASTROPHIC FOR AMERICA
THAN THIS HORRIFIC VIRUS ITSELF.
WHAT CHANGES IN OUR BEHAVIOR
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THIS
HEALTH INSURANCE CRISIS?
SOME OF WHAT WE HEARD LAST
SEGMENT.
SIMPLE THINGS.
>> IT’S IMPORTANT WE TAKE
PRECAUTIONS.
WASHING OUR HANDS.
KEEPING OUR DISTANCE FROM PEOPLE
WHO ARE SICK AND TAKING STEPS TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE KNOW POSSIBLE TO
KEEP OUR MOST VULNERABLE
PROTECTED.
>> Laura: THAT’S RIGHT.
BECAUSE OF THE CDC BUNGLING THE
TESTS IN THE BEGINNING WE ARE
ONLY NOW SEEING THE TRUE NUMBERS
OF THOSE INFECTED.
THE UNKNOWNS ARE CAUSING
CONFUSION AND CONCERN.
NO ONE WANTS TO BE SUED.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES, NO
ONE WANTS TO BE SUED FOR NOT
USING AN ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION.
>> WE HAVE CLOSED SOME SCHOOLS.
WE CLOSED SCHOOLS IN NEW
ROCHELLE.
>> HARVARD TOLD STUDENTS TO MOVE
OUT AND NOT COME BACK AFTER
SPRING BREAK.
>> 24 STATES HAVE DECLARED
STATES OF EMERGENCY.
>> THE GOVERNOR’S ANNOUNCEMENT
OF NO PUBLIC GATHERS OF ANY
KIND, WEDDINGS OR SPORTS.
>> NOTHING SHOULD BE OFF THE
TABLE IN TERMS OF CLOSURES OF
EVENTS.
>> Laura: MAYBE CLOSING ALL OF
THE SCHOOLS AND WEDDINGS, MAYBE
THAT’S ALL WARRANTED.
MAYBE CANCELLING ALL OF THESE
EVENTS, MAYBE THAT’S THE PRUDENT
THING TO DO.
I SUPPOSE IT MEANS NO
GRADUATIONS EVEN FOR HEALTHY
PEOPLE.
LET’S SAY THINGS CALM DOWN BY
THE END OF APRIL.
THE VIRUS POPS UP AGAIN IN THE
FALL.
WILL THIS NEW PRECEDENT LONGER
TERM REQUIRE THAT WE CANCEL
EVERYTHING ALL ANEW.
NO MORE CAMPAIGN EVENTS LIKE
RALLIES.
NO MORE TOWN HALLS.
NO MORE INTERACTING WITH THE
VOTERS.
HOUR CONSTITUTION REQUIRES THAT
OUR POLITICAL PROCESS CONTINUE.
THIS CRISIS MUST NOT BE USED TO
HELP CANDIDATE OF EITHER PARTY
ESCAPE ACCOUNTABILITY IF THE
VOTERS?
NOR MUST IT BE USED TO GUILT
CANDIDATES IN CANCELLING EVENTS
FOR HEALTHY PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WILL PUSH BACK AGAINST
MASS HYSTERIA.
THE CORONAVIRUS WILL BE
DIFFICULT BUT WE WILL DO IT.
THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT SHOWED HE
CARES ABOUT MAINSTREAM AND ALL
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE ALL HAVE TO LIVE WITH A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF RISK.
WE GO OUT THE DOOR IN THE
MORNING.
WE TEMPER THAT WITH KNOWLEDGE
AND PRACTICALAL THINKING.
LET’S HELP EACH OTHER.
WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH MUCH WORSE.
WORLD WAR II AND THE DEPRESSION.
WE NEED TO STICK TOGETHER AND
NOT BE AFRAID TO ASK QUESTIONS